I want to talk about a business myth
that needs to die. It's something that
so many business owners believe and so
I'm going to explain what it is, how
it's applied to thousands of businesses
that have come to our headquarters here
at acquisitioners.com in Vegas and how
it's likely holding you back. And it's
one of the most insidious beliefs, and I
think it might be the one that ends the
most businesses. And the crazy part is
it has nothing to do with the business
and everything to do about how you treat
it. Now, I've had the same problem come
up again and again and again that I felt
the need to make this for you, which is
my business isn't scalable or shouldn't
I switch my business some to something
that's more scalable? Again, I might
gouge my own eyes out, but I the reason
that I that I'm so annoyed by it is that
basically every business has limits to
scalability and there are different
problems that occur at different times.
Now, I want to talk about this within
two different contexts. one is industry
context and secondary is um more on like
the demand and supply side. But I'm
going to I'm going to break this down in
a lot of different ways. So right off
the bat, if you have a service business,
for example, you hire humans to do
things for other humans, then that is a
business that's very easy to start, can
be very profitable, and then over time
can become a little bit more difficult,
not impossible, just more difficult to
scale quickly because maintaining
quality of service when you have other
humans doing things and you're bringing
them in and they don't know anything and
you have to train them becomes more
challenging. If we had kind of like the
middle of the path there, you've got
like an e-commerce business, which you
can start relatively quickly, but as you
scale up, you can scale up quickly, but
some of the issues become supply chain
and logistical problems, right? So, I'd
say that's kind of like in the middle,
right? It's it's a little bit slower to
start. It costs a little bit more money
to start. It does scale faster than
traditional service does, but you're
still going to run into some problems.
Now, all the way on the kind of extreme
side, you've got the the software
digital type businesses. Now these
businesses um are typically when I say
digital I mean SAS software not uh e
like not not digital products like
ebooks and courses things like that
these businesses cost the most amount of
time to start the most amount of money
to start but once you achieve scale they
become significantly easier relative to
the others and so I get this question of
like I don't think my business is that
scalable all the time when in reality
it's just harder to scale and so the
thing is is that switching from one
service business to another service
business in terms of overall category is
not likely to dramatically change your
growth trajectory at all. You're still
likely going to be constrained by
humans, which most businesses are. I'm
going to say this again. 78% of
businesses in the United States are
service-based businesses. Like, this is
this is reality. And the reason that
this is so annoying to me is that people
will come and want to break their
businesses. They won't want to abandon
their businesses because they think that
the woman in the red dress, they think
this other new thing somehow doesn't
have the same characteristics of a
people-based business. Now within that
category, let's say we have a service
business. You can have demand constraint
service businesses and supply constraint
service businesses. Each business has
problems. And the crazy part is is that
the problems are actually kind of
similar. So let me explain. So if you
have a demand constraint service
business, so you have a a a
brickandmortar fitness business, you're
going to be demand constrained as in
it's going to be harder to find people
want to work out than it is to find
people who want to teach people to work
out. Right? Finding trainers and fitness
enthusiasts, not that hard. finding
people who actually want to come in the
gym and get excited and ser you know
sign up for a service package or
something like that much more difficult
right on the flip side if you have an
accounting firm right getting um getting
getting people to do their accounting
everyone kind of has to do their
accounting but getting competent and
highquality accountants uh becomes the
issue now how do you solve each of those
problems you promote fundamentally you
promote to get new customers you promote
to get new accountants it's the same
problem you just have it on the back end
of the business or the front end of the
business. And some businesses have
alternate between whether supply or
demand constrained if you kind of grow
at the same rate. So you'll alternate
back and forth. But fundamentally, and
this is why I think this is so
important, you're going to struggle in
one way or the other. And the way that
you will solve it in either of those
situations is going to be through
promotion of some sort. And so the
reason that I bring this up is that said
differently, my business isn't scalable
means it's hard and I want it to be
easy. and can you just tell me that it's
going to be easy? And it's not. And so
difficulty is a feature, not a bug, of
scaling a business. It is something that
comes with scaling a business. And the
the reason I think this is so important
is that there are periods of time, and
sometimes those periods are not weeks,
but they are quarters, many quarters in
a row, where you have to sit with a
problem, as in you see the fire and it's
in your living room, and you have to
just let it burn. So let me explain what
I mean by this. There will be problems
that occur in the business. Let's say
that you're, you know, you're supply
constraint and you need to bring new
people in. Okay. So, once you decide,
okay, I can't handle more customers
because I have to hire more accounts. I
have to hire more HVAC people. I have to
hire more technicians at my auto shop,
whatever it is. As soon as you make that
decision, you see that clearly, you
start the promotional cycle. So, you
start kicking off ads, you start doing
some outreach, you start hitting up your
network, and then you start some
interviews, start some screening, and
then maybe you find uh one or two
people, and then you, you know,
interview them. And then maybe you give
them a job offer. And then once you give
them a job offer, you have to get them
trained up and be proficient. And you
might lose some of them because they're
not as good as you thought they were.
And other ones are good, but it still
takes three or six months for them to
scale up. And so all of a sudden, now
here, remember this what the feeling is
going to be like. You decided and you
realize that you were supply
constrained. You went out and you did
something about it. Good for you. But
once you start going out and doing
something about it, what happens?
Nothing. The business is still
constrained. And so you just suffer day
in and day out while you try and solve
this problem. And here's the nasty part.
Let's say that six months from now. But
remember, six months is 180 days of
every day you wake up and you're like, I
have this problem. I should do something
about it. And then you have to remind
yourself, I am doing something about it.
But the thing is is that your team is
still going to be struggling. They're
still going to be complaining. You might
still be complaining. And the thing is
is your brain, your monkey brain is
going to be like, we should do something
about this. But you are doing something
about it. It's just that the thing
you're doing about it isn't going to
solve it today. And the likelihood is
that, and this is where this is where it
gets nasty. This is where this is where
the real problems happen. This is why
this is such an important video. During
that waiting period is when the vast
majority of entrepreneurs [__] with
[__] So they change their model. They
change their price. They try they try
and change they're like, you know what?
Well, what if we change our deliverable
to, you know, it's it's 20 people per
account instead of 10 or five. And that
way we could, you know, we can keep
selling. But then all of a sudden your
service delivery drops and your churn
goes up and now you have a structural
issue within the business. Whereas when
you had your business that you had
before this without changing it, you had
good margins and good revenue retention.
Meaning like you kept making money and
people kept pay good. And so you take
something that's really good and because
you have a constraint on the system, you
break the business while you're waiting
for your solution that you already
started on to kick in. And so this is
where pain this is like this is the this
is the tangible of pain tolerance. So a
lot of people like to think about like
the rocky cut scene and things like that
like I'm in business. It's the grind.
The grind is often times realizing
there's a problem, beginning to try and
solve it, and then having to live with
that problem for not weeks or months,
but quarters and sometimes years. Hey
guys, real quick. If you're not sure if
you actually have a a slow solve problem
or a fast solve problem, like it's like,
man, I just don't know how to solve
this. We solve problems in businesses,
you know, every day at acquisition.com.
And my team looks at companies every
single month. And if you'd like to have
us take a look at the business, see like
where the constraint might be and maybe
how to uh to help, then you can click
somewhere around this video and you can
uh schedule a time to uh see if it's a
good fit for you to come out cuz uh this
is kind of what we do every day. And so
we've gotten pretty good at it. And uh
like I said, if that's valuable, click,
book a call. If not, enjoy the rest of
the video. And so the reason I'm
bringing this up is that then the next
thing that you start thinking is, well,
you know what? Maybe I'll have I'll
outsource this this problem to somebody
else. I'm going to delegate this away.
Sam Alman had this really good bit that
I saw on Instagram the other day and he
said he's the founder of OpenAI if you
don't know who he is. He says you can't
delegate the execution because the idea
and even the product or service often
times though exciting is not the hard
part. That's like the 10% of the
business. I mean it's fun. You have lots
of iterations, lots of changing, but
then once you have it and people are
buying it and they like it and you make
money at the end of the month, the 90%
of everything else is the actual
execution. It's the doingness. And then
doing this is the part where you have
unrelenting problems that either you are
actively solving and have not seen the
fruits of your labor or you're just
solving the micro problems that happen
every day. And all the while you have to
resist the urge to break the thing that
actually works that you spent all of
this other time getting all these
iterations getting punched in the face
to find the thing that actually worked.
And the likelihood that when you change
the thing that actually works to
something that's not that thing and that
that other thing is going to work better
than the first thing is low. And that's
the crazy part. Think about this from a
hypothetical perspective. If I have a
building, right, I've got bricks all
along each of the walls to create the
building, right? There are unlimited
places that those bricks could be in the
physical world. They could be in China,
you know, like I'm saying like if I had
a,000 bricks, brick number 999 could be
in its exact place where it needs to be
for the building, or it could be in
unlimited other places. But only in one
of those locations is it serving the
purpose of keeping the building upright.
And so often times when we move bricks,
what we're doing is the likelihood that
the move that we have is going to take
that brick from something that already
works in the building to improving the
strength of the building versus just
being a Jenga block that we remove or we
put on the side or we just put it across
the street. And then we think that it's
going to improve the building when in
fact the likelihood that when we change
something that works that it works
better is usually significantly lower.
And so I want to I want to dovetail into
kind of a third bigger idea here which
is features and bugs. And I referenced
it a little bit earlier but I want I
want to hit on it really hard. And to
use the words of my great uh CFO
Suzanne, she said, "All businesses have
[__] All businesses have features and
bugs." But I think one of the big
mistakes is that founders believe that
the feature is a bug when it really
isn't. And so if you have, let's say, a
service business, then you're going to
be like, "Man, it's hard to find good
people. I should change my business
model." Well, people's the business.
That's a feature. That's something that
comes standard with the business. You're
never going to eliminate it. It's going
to be part of it. If you were like,
"Man, I am a software, you know, uh,
company." Then guess what? The problem
that you're going to have is finding
good software developer. They're really
hard to find and they're really
expensive and so you going to still have
to manage those people. Now, of course,
there are problems in business that you
can solve. It's just that there's a lot
of businesses that you manage rather
than solve. You don't you never get
through them. It's just like basically
this pain of business that just it's
just overhead. It's just something that
you have to keep paying. And so like I I
feel like this is so important because
this is what understanding this took me
a very long time and you must do the
hard thing and a lot of the hard thing
is basically withstanding the pain of
knowing that there were mistakes being
you know occurring in the business.
There's churn that's going up and if we
had these people we wouldn't have this
churn but I can't change the business
because I'm actively getting those
people. So you just have to sit there
and watch it burn. You have to be okay
with the flaws and it will drive you
insane because as a person you need to
be the type of person who's not okay
with flaws. But you have to be willing
to deal with the flaws as they exist
because you are already actively solving
them. And you have to look at your team
in the face and be like, "Yep, heard."
And they're like, "We're doing there's
all these fires." You're like, "Yep,
understood. What are we going to do
about it right now? We're already
working on it." Well, why isn't it done
yet? It's in progress. What? What? It's
in progress. Well, shouldn't we do this
in the meantime? No. We're just going to
continue. We're going to endure. We're
going to persist. We're going to deal.
And I think that season is the part that
is the hard part. And the thing is is
that season is literally never ending
because as soon as you once once you you
you find your mechanics, you find your
accountants, you find the software
developers who are going to help you
with your business, whatever it is,
right? As soon as you find those people,
guess what happens? Something else will
break. And you'll have some things that
are fast fixes, and you'll fix those
fast. But some fixes are slow fixes. And
the slow fixes are the one that are
going to be the vast majority of your
business career. Because the fast fixes
are only there for a small period of
time because you deal with the pain, you
see the you see the solution, and you
solve it. Done. Over. But then as soon
as you go fast, fast, fast, slow, then
you just got to stick with that slow one
until it's solved. This is what makes it
hard. And it's not that your business
isn't scalable. It's that you want
scaling to be easier. And that's the
issue. Your business isn't broken. You
don't need to change the business. You
need to deal with the fact that
solutions take time and that this might
just be a feature of the business you're
in. Now, part of you might think, well,
if this is a feature of the business
that I'm in, uh, I don't want to have
this business. Okay. Well, if let's walk
through that. So, hypothetically, if you
were very good at solving that problem,
would that be a problem that you'd be
more okay with dealing with? Maybe. And
if you're considering an alternative
path, you should also consider the
alternative problems, right? You're
like, "Well, I want to do something
else." Okay, tell me all the things that
suck about that path because I promise
there are things that suck about that
path. And then the FOB question of that
is, are you better equipped to solve
those problems? Now, in the hypothetical
world, you always think you're better
equipped to solve those problems, but
often times you've never even solved
them before. And maybe the problems you
think that are there are not actually
the real problems. The real problems are
much deeper and more nefarious than the
ones you currently deal with. And so, I
think that there's some something so
deep about the saying the devil, you
know, right? is that like the business
is the devil, you know, and you've maybe
been doing this for a year or two years
or five years or 10 years, however long
you've been in your industry, 20 years.
The thing is is the longer you've been
in industry, the more you've mapped the
the the system, right? You more you've
mapped the terrain. You understand the
good and you understand the bad and you
understand what to do about the bad. And
so, fundamentally, problems will not
end. And I think this is like it's
almost like a human problem that exists
with entrepreneurs is that they want
problems to stop and they will never
stop. they will never stop. You're
wishing for something that does not
exist. And in so doing, you are
consistently changing things about the
business that is working. It's probably
the same thing for people who hop from
rel relationship to relationship is they
want to think, I want to have I want to
find a relationship that has no
problems. It's not going to it's not
going to happen. You're not going to
find it. But the biggest problem is all
of all is that you think that there
shouldn't be problems. You have a
problem with your problems and that
problem is solvable. You decide that
there isn't a problem with having
problems. You accept that having
problems is a fact of life. It's a fact
of business. It's a fact of wherever
you're trying to go. Like find me one
$100 million, $10 million, million
dollar, billion dollar entrepreneur who
says, "I got here and there were no
problems. In fact, today I have actually
solved all of my problems." It doesn't
happen. And so we have this demand. We
have this wish. And that wish is the
actual biggest problem in your business
because it's the thing that's causing
you to break the thing that's working.
And this is where you need to give time
time. You need to give solutions time to
breathe. And you need to give solutions
time to work. And as always, once the
solution actually happens, play it out.
Let's say that we've got we finally
fixed our accounting our accounting
recruiting problems. We now have lots of
accountants. We created a whole school
for accounting. We made 20 partnerships
with different accounting schools. And
now we have this we have guys banging
down the door being like, "Man, I would
love to work for you. What's your
problem now?" Well, you know what? Now
that I've got all these accountants,
I've got all these guys with empty empty
calendars. They could I have so much
more capacity. I'm I'm overpaying in
payroll because I got all these guys,
but I need to get more customers. And so
what do you do? You start marketing
more, but now but now the customers are
coming in because you're trying to fill
slots. You're you're lowering your bar.
You're taking worse quality customers.
Now your churn becomes an issue, right?
And your margins start going down
because you can't charge these people as
much and you've already taken on more
fixed costs because you started hiring
all these people. Huh? Is this sounding
familiar? These are sounding like
business problems. Because wouldn't it
be convenient if that accountant would
say, "Hey, uh, I will wait here
patiently until you have acquired 20
accounts of appropriate size and then
and only then will I choose to come on
board." And at that moment, you can
collect their revenue and all of these
customers will say, "You know what? I
will I will wait in line until you get
19 more customers just like me. And then
all at once, we will start working with
this new account that you're bringing in
so that your payroll and your revenue
can match." Wouldn't that be nice? It'd
also be nice if this table was made of
gold or diamonds. be sweeter if it were
diamond or adamantium, even cooler, but
very unlikely. And so, if you want to be
in the wishing game, then maybe
entrepreneurship isn't the right path
for you. But if you want to live in the
real world, you have to accept that
there will be problems and there will be
things and they they typically revolve
around one core issue, which is the
delta between your expectations around
time. So, let me explain what I mean by
this probably fourth concept. The
problem isn't your expectations of the
business. Your problem is the timeline
of those expectations. If you want to
change the world, you absolutely can. I
believe that wholeheartedly. I think any
one person, any one man, any one woman
can change the world. I believe that.
But not tomorrow. It will probably take
time. It will take infrastructure. It
will take help. It will take a movement.
It will take many other people helping
you along the way. And that does not
happen overnight. Like there's the
saying, Rome wasn't built in the dead.
And it's true. It wasn't. And so now
I'll give you a realistic timeline.
think um I I work on which is I work in
decades and the reason I choose that
number is that you can go from new idea
to massive global company in about 10
years. You look at a zero to a Microsoft
which they IPOed at about seven years,
right? You look at like obviously
OpenAI's like we saw their very rapid
growth but they're also they worked
since like 2017 and now they're what
like eight years in. So again, 7 years,
6 years, I I round a little higher
because, you know, I don't think I'm I'm
Elon Musk. And maybe you don't think you
are either. And if you're politically
charged about it, pick a different
entrepreneur, whatever. The point is the
rush you have is imaginary. It's not
real. It's in your head. You've made it
up. To get to where, by, when, why,
like, why? Like, we have to double this
year. Why? Maybe the fact that you think
you have to double this year is the
reason you'll never double over the next
five years because you keep trying to
cut corners. You can't build it right.
And because you don't build it right,
you don't get the right people in on the
front end. You don't get pe right people
in the back end. You get the wrong
talent. You get the wrong customers. You
keep turnurning this up because of
arbitrary arbitrary completely made up
lines that you draw in the sand and say
this must occur. And so I think if you
you can have the business you want, just
not by the time that you want it. And so
I don't think you need to change your
dreams. I think you need to change your
timelines. And so the idea that your
business isn't scalable is actually yet
again in relation to speed. Of course,
it's scalable. It's just not as
scalable. It doesn't scale as fast as
you'd like it to. And what part of this
can we change? The as you'd like it to.
That part you can change. Now, of
course, you could advertise more. You
could try and hire a bigger recruiting
team within the constraints of your
business given the resources you have.
Sure, of course you can allocate more
resources, but you're not going to solve
it. These are features. And so, I think
a lot of people are wishing for a
business that has no difficulty. And if
you find it, let me know. But I've yet
to see it. And I've looked at a lot of
businesses and so I say this because
many of you probably one don't need to
change your business. Probably need to
keep doing the business you're on.
Number two, the business you're on is
probably scalable. All businesses are
scalable. It's just how hard is it to
scale? And when we translate hard into
what problems must I solve in order to
scale it? And what are the alternative
problems to this path that I would have
to encounter if I didn't follow this
path? Which you'll find are often also
equally difficult. And probably you're
less equipped to solve them because
you've never solved them before. And so
the idea is I want no problem. But
really, you're only trading problems.
And so, when you're thinking about, I
want this to not be this way. Think
about what what problems you'd rather
have. There's a big big big big pile of
problems in the middle of the table. All
the business owners are tossing them in
uh in the middle. And it's like you got
to throw your cards in, your problems
in, you got to pick somebody else's.
When you look at everybody else's, like,
ah, I don't know. I don't know if I
would pick them up. And the thing is,
the longer you deal with your problems,
the better you get at dealing with them.
Kind of like the longer you've dated
somebody, you're like, I kind of know
how to deal with this person. I know how
to deal with their crazy, right? And
over time, they kind of know how to deal
with your crazy, right? So, your
business probably isn't broken. It's
probably just not growing as fast as you
want because you are demanding that it
grow faster, but you are in so doing
trying to break things about your
business that were making it work in
order to get it to not work so that you
no longer have that problem and you
create another problem. And now you have
two problems to solve, which is harder
than one. Your timelines are the biggest
issue in the business. And the fact that
it is hard is a feature, not a bug. And
the vast majority of your business
career will be spent waiting in painful
tolerance of the solutions that you are
implementing to kick in. And you have to
deal with the lashings of life while
that's happening and look at everyone in
the team in the eyes and say we are
working on it. And they're going to be
like, well, why don't we change this?
And you have to look at them and say,
no. And they're going to say, but
there's this fire. And you're like,
"Yeah, but if we do your thing, then
we're going to have another fire and
we're also going to incur the cost of
change between both scenarios, which I
would rather just have pain one rather
than pain two and cost of change pain,
pain three." And so what it is, it's
erratic. It's frenetic energy. It's the
feeling like you must do something. And
if you do, if you do have that energy
and you're like, man, I got to do
something about it. Go to what you're
actually trying to do with the solution
and try and promote yourself. Go do take
some of the interviews yourself. Try and
speed up the cycles there. By all means,
try and speed it up. You're just not
going to eliminate it. These will be
features. These will be things that you
live with. And I'll leave you with one
thought. There's an old There's an old
saying, an old bull and a young bull.
And they see a bunch of, you know,
pretty cows at the bottom of a bottom of
a hill. And so the young bull is looking
at the old bull and he's like, "Hey,
let's chase let's go run down there and
uh and see if we can catch one to um
procreate with." And uh the old bull's
like, "No, that's a terrible idea." And
he's like, "Why?" He's like, "Well,
because if we charge down there, he's
like, "They're all going to scatter."
And the young bull's like, "Yeah, but
I'm going to I'm going to take this. you
know, we'll each get one. He's like,
"Yeah, but if if we walk down the hill
slowly," he's like, "We can procreate
with them all." Now, how does this
relate to the business? Does this mean
that if I take my time, I can pursue
every single entrepreneurial endeavor? I
actually think that within the context
of entrepreneurship, it's backwards.
You're never going to sleep with all the
women. You can't. There are so many
businesses that exist. And the reason
for that, and you have more ideas than
you have time. And I think that there is
a there's a there's a fixed cost that we
must accept that it will likely take if
you really want to go big. It's going to
like look at the biggest businesses.
They're 20, 30, 40 years old and you're
like, "Well, I'm I'm 30 now." It's like,
"Right, that means until you're 70." One
thing you just keep growing. And so,
what does that what does that mean
downstream? It means that there are
opportunities, not just some
opportunities, but all other
opportunities besides the one that
you're currently working on, you will
have to say no to. Think about that
reality like let it settle with you
because you have to come to peace with
it. And the fact that you haven't come
to peace with it is why you keep wanting
to pursue all of these things. But by
pursuing all of them, you will get none
of them. You can't sleep with all the
women in the world. Doesn't matter what
your what your what your novelty desire
is. Like you have to understand that
this is fact of life. You're not going
to start every business. You're not even
going to start every great idea you
have. You're not even going to start
what 20% of the great ideas you have,
10%, 5%, one out of 20, one out of a
100red. You're gonna have one idea and
then you're going to have to keep
sticking with it because that's where
all the gains come in. It comes in the
compounding. It comes in the sticking
with it. Right? The hard part about the
plan isn't thinking about the plan or
doing the plan. It's sticking with the
plan. That's the hard part of the plan.
And believe me, and the frustration that
I'm having, the reason I'm like almost
shouting like this is because I'm
shouting at me. I'm not shouting at you.
I'm shouting at me because it's so hard.
Like this is what's hard. It's the hard
because it's a muscle you're not used
to. It's a skill that you have to learn.
You have it's a trait you have to flex
over and over and over again. And I will
say this, the more you say no, the
better you get at it. It never goes away
how hard it is. It just gets a little
bit easier. Just gets a little bit
easier with time. And eventually, I
think you'll know that you will have
appropriately flexed that muscle when
you can have no FOMO. If you can hear
that someone else is doing great and be
like, "That's amazing for them. I know
my game. I've been doing this for six
years. I've been doing this for eight
years. I'm going to keep doing my game."
And I think a lot of it is that we have
this desire for permanence. We have this
desire for legacy. We have this desire
to to live forever. When outside of
Brian Johnson, no one else is really
talking about that. And up until this
point, the death rate on humans is 100%.
And the forget the likelihood of
forgetting of a a human's life is also
close to 100%. And of the people who are
remembered, they're not remembered by
the people they know. They're remembered
by people they don't know. And by the
way, they're dead. And so, we have this
desire. And I think it just comes into
direct conflict with the idea that we
just live finite lives. Time moves
faster than you think. And the younger
you are, the less you realize that the
older you are, the more you start going
like, "Man, that was pretty quick." You
only have a couple a couple big bullets
in it. You got a couple decades, you
know, or couples, too. So, a few got
three, four, maybe seasons. And if you
really want to go big and something
starts working, then you're going to do
that thing for 30 or 40 years. And so,
like the idea of like, oh, I'm going to
own all these like you have divisions
within a business if it makes sense. But
most of the time, it doesn't. Most of
the time, you could start this other
thing or you could just do more of the
thing that's already working. Why is it
happening faster? because you're
demanding that it happen faster. But
there's nothing wrong with your inherent
business. You're saying the problem is a
problem that you created. Basically, you
just take reality, you move the line of
expectations, and then you say there's a
problem. And I see more businesses
ruined because of that than just about
anything else. You could make it work if
you just stuck with it. And you stop
thinking that there's something wrong
with your business. And maybe look at
the fact there might be something wrong
with your expectation. That's what I
got. That's my That's my Thursday th
Thursday thirst trap sermon. Thurman, if
you like this video, uh, I made a video
about figuring out whether your business
is supply or demand constrained. If
you're like, I don't know which one it
is. Um, and you can go check that out
around my head somewhere.